foreign
it is arguably one of the most important
cases of our time and you probably
haven't even heard about it Business
Insider has the report about a court
decision in France that though it may
have no legal bearing on the United
States still represents a historic wind
for the most persecuted group in the
western world and by that I am of course
referring to introverts reading from
Business Insider it says a French court
has ruled that companies can't fire
their workers for failing to be
sufficiently fun which I guess good news
for Rhonda santis as well the ruling
comes after a man referred to as Mr T
was fired from the Paris consultancy
firm cubic Partners in 2015 for refusing
to participate in after work drinks and
team building activities according to
the court documents Mr T joined the firm
in February 2011 was promoted in 2014
but was fired a year later in March 2015
for professional incompetence
specifically his refusal to adhere to
the company's fun values cubic Partners
also said Mr T was difficult to work
with and a poor listener in a judgment
issued on November November 9th the
court found that because Mr T's lack of
participation in the company's fun
values and critical Behavior were
reasons cited for his dismissal he had
been wrongfully fired by cubic Partners
the Court ruled that Mr T was exercising
his freedom of expression by refusing to
participate in the company social
activities and that performing this
fundamental Freedom could not be a
reason for his dismissal
now
we're going to kind of look over the
fact look past the unfortunate fact that
this man is fighting for his god-given
right to not be fun fighting for his
right to not party
you might say and yet the court has
given him the pseudonym Mr T which is a
very fun nickname so even while
vindicating his right to not be fun they
are still forcing funness on him in a
way that I find frankly disrespectful
be the resume this man does not want to
go to the company parties he does not
want to do the after hours team building
my God can you imagine that team
building while you're on the clock is
horrific
when you're supposed to be home and
they're telling you to come team build
doesn't want to do that he doesn't want
to socialize
he doesn't want to be fun he wants to be
boring damn it he wants to go home and
get away from all these people as is his
natural human right as enshrined by the
Geneva Convention or as it should have
been in tried at any rate and I bring
this up because it is it is a rare
Victory indeed for introverts in Western
culture this is a subject introversion
that's been on my mind over the last
couple of days after Fielding a
particularly disturbing email from a
listener during our members block
segment which you have to be a member to
watch by the way if you're not and the
message came from a woman who was
disappointed with her introverted
husband because he refused to dance with
her now in truth
a reluctance to dance has very little to
do with introversion as I'll explain in
a moment even even so
I support a man's right to not dance as
much as I support his right to not give
in to the social pressure to have fun
with his co-workers
and when it comes to dancing as I
explained to the woman uh some of us are
are born with what I call the dancing
Instinct that is the innate desire to
convulse our bodies in strange and
arbitrary ways as a physical response to
music and some of us are born without
that maladaptive and psychotic
compulsion those without it never feel
comfortable dancing and there's no
amount of social pressure or
guilt-tripping that will change that but
it's the subject of introversion that uh
interests me today in fact I talked
about this once on the show
back in the early days when I was
ranting alone in my car which as it
happens is in many ways the introvert's
ideal format for hosting a podcast and
that show recorded I think like four
years ago went semi-viral on YouTube
just a few months ago for whatever
reason and ever since that I've been
getting messages from my fellow
introverts thanking me for speaking up
in defense
of our community if you can even call it
a community because we're all
anti-social and I figured now's a good
time to revisit the subject and flush
out a few points especially in light of
this um Cortes the hard year in the
economy means that essential practical
gifts will begin high demand this year
so you can give the most essential and
practical gift of all America's best
meat and seafood from good Ranchers with
with discounts on orders of five boxes
or more you can save on gifts for the
whole family when you give a box of good
ranchers you're giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with a 100
American USDA prime and uppercut Choice
cuts of beef Chicken and Seafood other
meat delivery companies and even your
local grocery store they import lower
Quality Meat from overseas don't give
that to your friends don't give your
friends a family and family less than
America's best this year not sure what
to order good ranchers now offers gift
cards so you can let your friends and
family choose for themselves or give the
gift of a subscription and inflation
proof someone's meat budget so go to
goodranters.com use promo code Walsh to
check out to get 35 off your gift that's
goodranchers.com code Walsh for 35 off
good ranchers American Meat delivered
and we should begin with the most basic
point
which is usually lost in these
conversations which is to Define what an
introvert actually is
and here's the important Point introvert
is not a shy person not necessarily
anyway
a shy person is someone who is nervous
or timid in social situations
shy people have social anxiety
introverts can be shy but they need not
be in my case I'm an introvert without
question but I can get up and speak in
front of big crowds of people without
any problem that's not something a shy
person can easily do so I'm not shy
therefore but I am introverted how is
that possible well because put simply an
introvert is someone for whom
socializing is maybe not terrifying but
physically and mentally draining
okay that's what that's what we we are
trying to explain
an introvert is is most energized by
spending time alone or in much smaller
groups like maybe with their family an
extrovert on the other hand is energized
by busier and louder and more active
social situations
an introvert finds these kinds of social
interactions exhausting while an
extrovert finds them invigorating
somehow
but here's the important point
although the extrovert's proclivities
are mysterious to me
I still recognize that it isn't wrong
okay neither personality type is wrong
there are benefits to both introverts
tend to be more observant more
thoughtful better prepared more
self-aware more intuitive
while extroverts tend to be babbling
morons
I'm just kidding of course sort of I
mean extroverts tend to be they're
friendlier they tend to be more
enthusiastic they're more they tend to
be more bold more assertive there's some
crossover here of course
for example I may I may you know not be
an extrovert but I don't feel like I'm
lacking an assertiveness yet as a
general rule these are how the
personality types shake out the problem
is that our culture for all let's talk
about tolerance and diversity actually
has very little tolerance for a
diversity of personality types
we have very little tolerance for that
and in many contexts particularly in the
school system or in professional
environments Etc introverts are looked
at with suspicion
like there's there's again especially in
school system there's one
way to be like there's one personality
type they want you to have and if you
don't have that then it's suspicious
uh and they might even put you on drugs
to fix it
or at the very least they're going to be
constantly berated to open up come out
of your shell talk more the message is
that this way of being this disposition
is somehow incorrect
and but it rarely goes the other way the
extra extroverts are not encouraged to
be more introverted talkative people are
rarely asked to shut their mouths for
five seconds so the rest of us can hear
something other than their voices for a
change
assumptions are made though about the
introvert it isn't assumed that he's um
you know it's assumed that he isn't
talking because he's snobbish stuck up
standoffish anxious whatever
it's rarely considered that he might not
be talking simply because there is
nothing he feels like saying at the
moment
that's it just someone says why are you
talking I don't feel like saying
anything right now that's it that's all
right it's I'm not imposing on you
some people are satisfied to think
without verbalizing what they're
thinking
there are people who actually enjoy that
they enjoy thinking
without without having to immediately
funnel all of those uh thoughts out of
their mouths and into the world
and these people are called introverts
and there's nothing wrong with them
I think this discomfort with introverts
is largely driven
by our general discomfort with with just
quietness okay we live in a very loud
culture in every moment of every day is
filled with noise with activity with
communication with just lights and
sounds and blaring screens and hustle
and bustle and everything
they're people who walk around with with
headphones or earbuds in all day so so
they never have to endure a single
moment of silence
now introverts though don't have this
fear of Silence
on the contrary We crave it
that's when we do our best to work
that's when we can think and create and
hatch our devious schemes to take over
the world we're not afraid of quiet you
know but the culture is
and so then is afraid of us by extension
and that is why the French Mr T's Court
victory was so important and it's why he
is not canceled today but the
extroverted oppressors
certainly are
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as you move over to the
aforementioned members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]